[Música]
los demócratas se aseguraron uno de los
dos asientos al senado por georgia el
pastor evangélico raphael warnock se
quedó con una de las plazas que definirá
la mayoría en el senado de eeuu entre
tanto el también demócrata jon o soft as
lleva una ligera ventaja sobre el
republicano dave y verdú tenemos
reportes desde atlanta
también en eeuu el congreso se reúne
para la certificación de los votos del
colegio electoral que ratificarán la
victoria de joe biden como presidente
del país hasta ahora 12 senadores
republicanos han anunciado que no
reconocerán los resultados y seguidores
de donald trump adelanta protestas en
vagina
duro golpe a la oposición en hong kong
53 opositores fueron detenidos según
beijing por violar la polémica ley de
seguridad nacional que ha generado meses
de protestas en el territorio
semiautónomo entre los arrestados se
encuentran varias de las figuras más
relevantes del partido democracia
bienvenidos a una nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo aquí en tras 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en eeuu
porque los demócratas ya aseguraron una
plaza más en el senado y estarían cerca
de conseguir la segunda tras las
elecciones de este martes en georgia
donde se define la mayoría de la cámara
alta
el resultado es clave para la gestión
del presidente electo joe biden
el pastor afroamericano raphael warnock
derrotó a la republicana carly löffler
en la segunda vuelta de los comicios en
el estado el segundo asiento aún no se
decide pero el retador demócrata jon o
soft lleva una pequeña ventaja sobre el
republicano david verdú según las
proyecciones la victoria a war no hay
acerca de los demócratas al control de
la cámara alta
así que georgia le honra la fe que han
mostrado en mí y les prometo que voy al
senado a trabajar para todos georgia sin
importar por quién votaron en esta
elección en este momento de la historia
estadounidense washington tiene una
decisión que tomar de hecho todos
tenemos que tomar una decisión
continuaremos dividiendo distrayendo y
faltando nos al respeto o amaremos a
nuestro prójimo como a nosotros mismos
william herschel
ampliamos la información con nuestro
enviado especial atlanta georgia anthony
welsch y anthony cuéntenos que hace
falta para conocer el segundo ganador de
estas elecciones
así que está muy buenos días
efectivamente por un lado ya está
confirmado ese asiento en la cámara alta
por parte de raphael warnock el el
candidato demócrata con el 56% y luego
frente al 49,4 por ciento de qué ley lo
fer pero ahora la contienda está entre
jon o soft y david verdú el demócrata
contra el republicano de hecho el centro
de investigación es edison que están
monitoreando ese escrutinio que ahora
mismo está al 98 por ciento el candidato
demócrata estaría liderando el recuento
de votos con el 50,2 por ciento sin
embargo tanto la campaña demócrata como
la republicana son muy cautelosos o
porque dicen que hasta que no se cuente
hasta el último voto y no se pueda
confirmar el que efectivamente uno u
otro candidato ha ganado no podrán
celebrar la victoria aliviana anthony
cuéntenos ahora en caso de ganar los dos
democrátas las dos plazas quiero decir
que representaría esto para la
presidencia de joe biden
sí es importante remarcar que los
demócratas necesitan ganar los dos
escaños que actualmente poseen los
republicanos mientras que el partido
republicano solo necesitaba un
asegurarse un escaño para liderar la
cámara alta sí
qué significa eso básicamente que si los
republicanos lideran el senado de eeuu
podrían bloquear automáticamente la
agenda prevista del nuevo gobierno de
joe biden eso pasaría por ejemplo en
anular la reforma migratoria de la que
se comprometió el entonces candidato by
den a presentar durante los primeros 100
días de su gobierno y luego también
incluso anular el obamacare la reforma
sanitaria que tanta polémica ha causado
en el país pues es la información con
anthony ver si nuestro enviado especial
atlanta georgia gracias por la
información y entretanto en washington
la capital de eeuu seguidores del actual
presidente de donald trump se
concentraron desde la noche de este
martes para pedir el bloqueo de la
formalización de la victoria de bailén
horas antes de la sesión conjunta del
congreso para certificar los resultados
de las presidenciales miles manifestaron
su apoyo al presidente toma la protesta
responde al llamado hecho por el propio
mandatario para rechazar la victoria de
maiden se esperaba que tron hable hoy
contra el congreso
normalmente la certificación de los
votos del colegio electoral por parte
del congreso es una simple formalidad
pero este año se va a convertir en un
enfrentamiento acalorado una docena de
legisladores republicanos tienes a
donald trump planean desafiar los
resultados
solo unos días después de que el nuevo
congreso fuese jurado está previsto que
una sesión explosiva tenga lugar el
miércoles cuando los legisladores voten
para certificar los resultados
electorales de noviembre por lo general
la certificación de los votos del
colegio electoral es un proceso formal
pero decenas de legisladores
republicanos leales a donald trump
planean desafiar la certificación
respaldando los continuos esfuerzos del
presidente para invalidar los resultados
impulsados por afirmaciones no aprobadas
de fraude electoral en diversos estados
clave las objeciones forzarán debates
tanto en el congreso como en el senado
dividiendo hacia los republicanos y
forzándoles a decidir entre mostrar
lealtad a trump o confirmar públicamente
la victoria del presidente electo joe
biden
la maniobra pone al vicepresidente mike
pence uno de los defensores más leales
de tram en una posición especialmente
incómoda como presidente del senado debe
contar los votos de cada estado y
anunciar el resultado haciendo efectiva
la derrota formal de trump pero trump
está presionando le para rechazarla
también
tengo que decir que confío en que mike
pence esté con nosotros por supuesto si
él no nos apoya ya no me agradará tanto
aún así para que el congreso anule los
resultados ambas cámaras deben votar
para hacerlo con los demócratas
controlando la cámara de representantes-
parece seguro que la propuesta fracasará
cuando yo by the end y yo seamos
juramentados el 20 de enero que lo
seremos europe joe biden será el próximo
presidente de eeuu y yo sería la próxima
vicepresidencia mientras tanto trampa ha
instado a sus seguidores a protestar por
el conteo del voto electoral se espera
que miles de personas se manifiesten en
washington el miércoles
hoy se conocerá la decisión de la
justicia británica sobre la petición de
libertad condicional hecha por los
abogados de julian assange la petición
de la defensa se registró tras el
rechazo de la solicitud de extradición a
eeuu del fundador de wikileaks los
abogados pidieron la libertad inmediata
argumentando que assange permanecería en
londres junto a su familia y bajo
vigilancia de las autoridades
vamos ahora a hong kong donde 53
opositores fueron detenidos por violar
la polémica ley de seguridad nacional
impuesta por china en julio del año
pasado
entre los detenidos hay figuras muy
relevantes del partido democrático las
detenciones suponen el mayor golpe
registrado contra la oposición lo cual
ha causado un gran impacto entre los
ciudadanos veamos el informe de álvaro
cordero
la oposición hongkonesa recibió el mayor
golpe de los últimos meses 53 miembros
cercanos al movimiento prodemocrático
fueron arrestados la excusa de las
autoridades es que estas personas
intentaron socavar al gobierno con la
celebración de unas primarias
clandestinas de cara a los comicios
legislativos que se iban a celebrar en
septiembre de 2020 wi-fi hemos arrestado
a 53 personas por los delitos de
subversión bajo la ley de seguridad
nacional
ignacio nos sacudimos también a funding
son equipo capitán eso significa que
estamos encontrando que algunas personas
han estado interfiriendo seriamente
interrumpiendo y socavando el
funcionamiento del gobierno de hong kong
por medio de un plan para bein
y estas elecciones finalmente no se
realizaron con el pretexto de la
pandemia y permitieron seguir
conservando el poder en la cámara al
partido oficialista de carril am el
hecho de que las detenciones se
produjeran bajo la acusación de violar
la ley de seguridad nacional es grave ya
que ésta contempla la cadena perpetua en
casos de intento de secesión o
confabulación con fuerzas extranjeras
una decisión que impactó a la ciudadanía
al ver las noticias hoy me sentí
completamente conmocionada me siento muy
decepcionada están sucediendo cosas muy
importantes en hong kong y no hay nada
que podamos hacer al respecto
hong kong lleva más de año y medio de
protestas contra lo que la oposición
considera una regresión de la democracia
y un acercamiento a los postulados de
beijing
finalizamos con imágenes que nos llegan
desde la ciudad de belene y es que hoy
se celebra el día de la epifanía que
recuerda la llegada de los reyes magos a
belén para entregar regalos a jesús
recién nacido la plaza del pesebre
permanece vacía debido al impacto del
coi 19 y ustedes pueden continuar con
más nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]